[Music]  let's talk about american horror story  it was just  revealed a week and a half ago that your  character  serial killer yeah and this is the  second time i didn't know until it aired  it was so weird  [Laughter]  that i was the one yeah but it is the  second time that i've played a uh uh a  cereal you're a serial killer on heroes  yeah and and as serial killer now  what is  it what is it about zachary quinto that  says serial killer what is it i've been  talking to my therapist about that for  the last six years uh i don't know  i really don't know uh my strong brow  i think yeah get in on those eyes  getting tight on those eyes yes  those yes  yes it really is it really is the  downward uh position of the head with  the upward glass yes  i don't have that i have a creepy  pervert that's what i have  [Applause]  there's value in that too  especially in this town  [Laughter]  i'll always work